DANIEL SIEBERG: Hi there.
I'm Daniel Sieberg
with I/O Live.
And we are at the
Google+ Sandbox.
And I am joined right now by
Timothy Jordan, who is a
senior developer advocate, going
to be our virtual tour--
wait, you're not virtual.
You're real.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I feel real.
I mean, I just kind of--
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah,
you're quite real.
So you're going to be our
real tour guide--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yes.
DANIEL SIEBERG: --here
for the Sandbox.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yes.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So tell
me, first of all,
what's over my shoulder?
Let's start maybe our
right to left--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Right
over there?
DANIEL SIEBERG: --the
left to right.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Left
of the screen?
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah,
left of the screen.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That
thing over there?
DANIEL SIEBERG: Exactly.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: We've got two
Google+ Hangout booths.
Now, they're showcasing Google+
applications that were
just recently announced, one by
Goko and the other by the
Art Project.
And we're going to learn more
about both of those.
DANIEL SIEBERG: [INAUDIBLE]?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: We've got
Office Hours right here.
Now, this is where any attendee
at Google I/O can
just come right up and talk to
a Googler, and get their
questions answered about
the platform.
DANIEL SIEBERG: No question
too big or too small?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yes.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Over here,
we have the lounge area.
Now it's kind of like Office
Hours but a bit more casual.
Go there to hang out and
exchange ideas with your
fellow developer or Googlers,
if we happen to
be there doing some--
DANIEL SIEBERG: I get
that, hangout.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hey.
We call it a Hangout
In Real Life--
DANIEL SIEBERG: Nice.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: --or a HIRL.
Right over here, we've
got two demo booths.
One is Google+ History.
And the other is Google+ Events,
both announced here at
Google I/O, which takes us to
another announcement at that
big old wall showing the tablet
experience on the Nexus
7 tablet that we
just announced.
And it's really beautiful.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Now, what
is this display that's
going on over here?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: This is one
of my favorite parts.
DANIEL SIEBERG: #io12, right--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You write--
DANIEL SIEBERG: --let's
you know about.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: --a post
with #io12 on Google+.
And there's a good chance it's
going to be showing on this
wall at some point during Google
I/O. It's using the
Google+ API to grab those posts
and do this great visual
representation here
on the floor.
And I think it's actually a
really cool way that we're
bridging the conversation
between here at Moscone and
the rest of the internet that's
also at Google I/O. You
know we have over 30,000, I
think it is, developers
joining I/O extended.
So if you're out there, hello.
DANIEL SIEBERG: I think I saw
your name go up there.
All right, well let's go take a
look at the Hangout booths.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah,
let's do that.
Here we are with Goko.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yes, and
Alexander from Goko joins us.
ALEXANDER SHEN: Hi,
how's it going?
DANIEL SIEBERG: So we're looking
at a computer game
here, as you might
play, of course.
But you've integrated the
Hangouts into the game.
And you're in a Hangout
right now.
Tells us about that.
ALEXANDER SHEN: That's right.
So what Goko is, basically,
we're a games company in a
development platform.
And what we've done is that
we are helping HTML 5 game
developers create some really
great games, and offer things
like multi-player, virtual
economies, things like that.
So what we've done is
we've partnered
with Rio Grande Games.
And we have Dominion here.
And Dominion's a very popular
deck-building game.
So we have this board game.
We have Google+ Hangouts
on the bottom.
Because this way we can
integrate video chat, and be
able to play with multiple
players across the country,
and make it feel like we're
at the same table.
But we're not.
And with this game, we just have
some really nice artwork
from the game company.
And we're just trying to create
this traditional game
experience in a digital
format.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And the graphics
are beautiful.
But you can also include some
aspects of Hangouts, like
facial tracking,
into the game.
ALEXANDER SHEN: That's right.
So one of the things we did--
and one of the great offers
that Google+ Hangouts has-- that
we can use face tracking
data, and essentially overlay
images from the game.
So if I'm playing my friend
right now, and I decide to
play the minion card, over on my
head you'll see right here
I've got the minion head
face tracking me.
It's like, aw, he's played
the minion card.
It's awful.
So this way we know--
it's just a little more fun.
It makes you actually feel
like not only playing
Dominion, but you're
kind of in it.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And when you're
trash talking, you can
actually see people just
like you would in
person, too, right?
ALEXANDER SHEN: Absolutely.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's great.
So if people want to play this,
when is it coming out?
How will it be integrated?
ALEXANDER SHEN: So right now you
can actually sign up for
the beta if you go to
dominion.goko.com.
And you sign up for
the beta there.
Or if you're a developer
interested in the platform,
goko.com, and you can
just sign up.
So all of these games and many
of our services will be
released later this summer.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And for anyone
who's curious about what that
development process was like
for Hangouts, can you maybe
offer some advice or
tips for people?
ALEXANDER SHEN: Definitely, the
documentation and being
able to work with the Google
team, it's been a blessing.
And it's very well documented,
and just having the right
people to take a
look at it all.
And it's really easy to use.
So just in general, just keep
at it and you'll be fine.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Cool, I'll let
you guys get back to your game
here, right?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah, we
don't want to keep you
from the play time.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yes, exactly.
All right.
Alexander, thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank
you, Alex.
Let's go check out some art.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK, all
right, good call.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hey,
Daniel, over here.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Hey, Timothy, I
lost you there for a second.
It's a big place.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So we're here
with Piotr who is with the Art
Project, which is a
pretty cool way to
experience art in a Hangout.
Piotr, can you start
by just telling us
about the Art Project?
PIOTR ADAMCZYK: Sure.
The Art Project is a platform
that we provide to museums and
institutions that want
to put more of their
art collections online.
We started about a year
ago with 17 museums.
And now we're up to 150
collections in 40 different
countries, about 30,000
works of art.
DANIEL SIEBERG: It's
absolutely amazing
what people can do.
But now, through the magic of
a Hangout, you can do these
same kind of tours of artwork
with your friends.
PIOTR ADAMCZYK: Yeah, we've
basically brought the Art
Project experience
inside a Hangout.
You can start a Hangout either
straight from Hangouts or from
the Art Project.
And whoever you're with can
either start a tour or share
the works of art that
they're looking at.
And you can interact
that way as well.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right, so
you're in a Hangout right now?
PIOTR ADAMCZYK: Yeah.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK, are
you leading this
tour or are you following?
PIOTR ADAMCZYK: No, actually,
a friend of mine, Marzia,
another developer on the Art
Project, is going to be
leading us through this
particular tour.
So we're just going to wait
until she starts it up.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right.
MARZIA NICCOLAI: So I'm going to
start a tour here so I can
show Piotr what happened
to me the other
day here in San Francisco.
PIOTR ADAMCZYK: So I'm just
joining Marzia's tour.
MARZIA NICCOLAI: Art Project
allows you to search by
collections, artists,
and artworks.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And this is
exactly what people would see
if they decided to choose
this within a Hangout?
PIOTR ADAMCZYK: Yeah, exactly.
It's just an app that you can
start up here at the top or
directly from the Art Project.
And now Marzia is just walking
us through the tour that she
has picked for us.
MARZIA NICCOLAI: OK, so
I saw this painting.
And it put me in mind of my
favorite story, that of the
titan Prometheus who brought
fire to the gods.
Here in the Art Project,
we can see what
happened to him in stages.
The first thing that happened
is Hephaestus, the god of
engineers, one of my favorite,
bound him to a rock.
So you can see here--
oh, look at that.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's
an unfortunate shot.
You know, Prometheus just
wanted us to be
warm, the poor guy.
MARZIA NICCOLAI: That's a--
DANIEL SIEBERG: Marzia decided
to pick a good one.
MARZIA NICCOLAI: Oh,
I misspelled it.
Then he's tied to a rock.
And you can see him here.
But the actual interesting thing
is you can see what's
about to happen to him.
We have the eagle.
And everyone knows that the
punishment for Prometheus
bringing fire to the gods
was him having his liver
perpetually chopped
out by the eagle.
PIOTR ADAMCZYK: You picked
really happy
ones for us, Marzia.
Thanks.
MARZIA NICCOLAI: So that is
the story of Prometheus.
And I did not realize how
inappropriate it would be
until I saw the zoom.
PIOTR ADAMCZYK: But the idea is
that you could look at all
the details of the
works of art.
And someone, an art expert or an
art lover, like Marzia, can
walk us through all of the
material and show us all the
details that are the most
interesting to them.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You know,
that's really cool.
I think this solves a problem,
being able to see art that you
wouldn't otherwise be able to
go see in person, and yet
still do it with your friends.
PIOTR ADAMCZYK: No,
absolutely.
And the opportunities for the
museums and other experts to
actually be able to reach a wide
audience using Hangouts.
Hangouts On Air, in particular,
the fact that you
can record and broadcast it to
as many people who won't be
able to come to the museum or
won't be able to hear the
curator talk about the work
that they know so well.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Right, so we
should say this integrates
into Hangouts On Air.
PIOTR ADAMCZYK: Yeah,
absolutely.
DANIEL SIEBERG: I mean
this is broadcasting,
being recorded somewhere.
It could be shared elsewhere
beyond just this experience.
PIOTR ADAMCZYK: So it's museum
educators and art lovers
around the world can go back
to it and find out more.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So one more
quick question for me is how
is your experience developing
with the Hangout APIs?
I mean this is really visually
rich, pulling that media in,
and showing it, and
synchronizing that across the
two screens.
PIOTR ADAMCZYK: I mean the Art
Project only launched about
two months ago.
So really we've been focusing on
the development of this and
other new features for the
rest of the Art Project.
So it's really quick and easy to
develop for Hangouts, a few
synchronization and message
passing things to make sure
that we could get the screens
to sync up across all of the
different machines and that the
state would be as light as
it could be so that it could be
really fast and responsive.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Well, I'm
not an artist at all.
But I can appreciate a great
app when I see one.
That is fantastic.
Piotr, thank you so
much for the--
PIOTR ADAMCZYK: Thanks a lot.
DANIEL SIEBERG: --virtual
tour.
PIOTR ADAMCZYK: Yeah,
of course.
DANIEL SIEBERG: We
appreciate it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks, Piotr.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right.
We got some more stuff to see.
We should go.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Let's do that.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right.
I'll race you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hey, Daniel.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Let's sneak
up on David Glazer.
DANIEL SIEBERG: I know.
Here he is.
He doesn't suspect
anything at all.
Hey.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: How
you doing there?
DAVID GLAZER: Good,
how are you guys?
DANIEL SIEBERG: We're
doing great.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: We're
doing really well.
Everybody out there, this is
David Glazer, a director of
engineering here at Google.
DAVID GLAZER: Hi.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So tell us a
little bit about the exciting
announcements related to
Google+, some of the sort of
things you're taking away
as developers that are
interacting with folks
here in the Sandbox.
DAVID GLAZER: Yeah, I think the
most, to me, personally,
the most exciting announcement
was there were a
whole bunch of stats.
The stat I was happiest about
was one, which is
we're one year old.
And for us who have been working
on this project for a
year, that's really the most
amazing thing is that, in the
12 months since we launched
Google+, so much has happened.
I went to a session today where
someone was talking
about some of the new features
in the platform.
And they said, this is the first
time we've talked about
Google+ at I/O. Because it
didn't exist last year at
Google I/O.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And for
developers, this is such a
huge opportunity for them to
tap into that, as well, and
have this kind of conversation
with different developers.
DAVID GLAZER: Yeah, so really
what happened over the last
year is we built up a base of
users, and usage, and features
that we then get to build on top
of, and some of the news
today was how we're doing that,
and then more ways for
developers to build on top of.
And that's what the rest
of the news was.
So I guess probably the number
I'm the second most excited
about after one was 250 million,
which is the number
of users who are now
Google+ users.
And having those 250 million
users means that we have
things to give them.
And so we launched Events.
I know you've talked to
some other people.
You've seen what's going
on with Google+ Events.
We have a big Event
that everyone here
is invited to tonight.
That's great.
We now have 250 million users
who can use that, invite their
friends, and share pictures,
and go into party mode, and
all of that.
We have ways for these users to
get to Google+ from a lot
more places.
So we have the new tablet,
which is awesome.
I have five emails from my son
who was watching at home.
He interrupted me every time a
new device was held up saying,
Christmas or July or can
you bring one home?
So we have all these
new places where
you can access Google+.
And the app is stunning
on the tablet.
The new UI on the new hardware
is just amazing.
It's hard to test, because I
keep getting lost in it.
I keep saying, oh, I'm supposed
to look for bugs.
And then I read for 15 minutes,
and then, oh, I'm
supposed to look for bugs.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's
probably a
good thing and allowed.
DAVID GLAZER: It's a
very good thing.
And then on the developer side,
on the platform side,
you heard today that we now have
more people using Google+
from mobile than from desktop.
And as a result, we've been
really beefing up the mobile
aspects of the platforms.
So we have new capabilities for
mobile developers to make
it easier for them to build
Google+ capabilities into
their application.
We announced the Google+
History API today.
It's an early developer
preview.
But it's a great way for
developers to help their users
save privately what they do in
their app, and then later
optionally share it, which,
in turn, leads to
more use of the app.
All of these new capabilities
are being built on top of the
250 million users in the
first year of stuff.
So it's fun.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right, well,
you were probably busy
doing something important.
So we're going to let you
get back to doing that.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: He's
finding bugs.
DAVID GLAZER: I'm pretending
to find bugs.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank you
so much for your time
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right,
David, we appreciate it.
All right, let's keep
moving here.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
All right, Daniel, now we're at
the Google+ History booth
with Silvano.
Silvano, how are you?
SILVANO LUCIANI: I'm very
party mode today.
So I miss it.
DANIEL SIEBERG: I'm
very excited to
learn more about this.
It sounds really cool.
SILVANO LUCIANI: So yeah, this
is the Google+ History API.
And it's an early developer
preview.
And like Instant Upload, it will
allow users to save their
online activities in a private
space, and then, if they want,
they can also share it.
And we launched this early
developer preview, because we
want the developers out there
to start experimenting with
this API to bring their
awesome content
to our Google+ users.
But let me show it to you.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yes,
please do.
SILVANO LUCIANI: And
I will use an API
starter that we have.
And it's open source.
And it's in our developer
documentation at
developers.googl
e.com/plus/history.
So the first thing,
you need the user
to sign in to Google+.
And this is very easy with
our sign in button.
As you can see, this is the
through flow that has gone
seamlessly.
Now, I can choose one
of the activities.
So let's say I want
to buy something.
I click on the Buy Activity.
That application is showing
me the JSON Exchange,
that it's going on.
And now I will show you, in the
Google+ user interface,
the moment that you've
read them.
And this is your moment.
I bought Alice's Adventures in
Wonderland, which is one of my
favorite book.
And if I want, I can
also share it.
And if you see, each snippet is
populated by the data that
you specified using
schema.org markup
when writing the moment.
And using the sharing model of
Google+, I can decide to make
this experience public or just
share it with my friend or
with my avid readers circle.
And there you are.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Now, if
developers want to get started
with a Google+ History API,
what's their first step?
SILVANO LUCIANI: So they
need to sign in.
And we have a very
easy procedure.
And you can find all the
information that you need at
developers.googl
e.com/plus/history.
And we just need your
email address.
We will sign up you
to a group.
And then you are up to go, and
start developing, and having
fun, and send us
your feedback.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Great.
Silvano, thank you so
much for this demo.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Thank
you for coming.
DANIEL SIEBERG: We
appreciate it.
All right, we've got
to run off to our
last appointment here.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah,
we're going to
go talk to the Events--
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yes.
Let's do it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: --Events
folks, yes, do that.
Hey, Kavi and Tina.
How are you doing?
DANIEL SIEBERG: What's
going on over here?
It sounds like Events is what
we're going to be talking
about right now.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: We've been
watching from home.
And by we, I mean, of course,
everybody watching from home.
And we saw the Events
announcement.
It looks really cool.
And I want a sneak peek at what
you can do with this.
TINA CHEN: Great.
Google+ Events captures the way
people experience events
in real life.
Because an Event doesn't end
when you RSVP, we wanted to
help people capture important
moments as they happen, and
help them share and revisit
those memories afterwards.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So it's kind
of this before, during, and
after idea, which I love.
So maybe give us a walk
through here.
KAVI HARSHAWAT: Yeah,
absolutely.
So when you're ready to create
an Event, you can go to
Google+, and click on the
Events icon at the top.
And you can create all different
types of events,
everything from picnics
and barbecues to
weddings and even concerts.
You can create a virtual Event
using Google+ Hangouts, and
then share them with
whoever you like.
And when you're ready to share
them, you can actually share
them with circles or
individuals, including people
who are not yet using Google+.
And after you've created the
Event, the people you invited
will actually see the Event in
their Google+ stream, in
email, Google+ notifications,
or even in
their Google Calendar.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So they
really have no
excuse for missing anything.
TINA CHEN: And during the Event,
you'll be able to turn
on party mode.
Whenever party mode is on, new
photos you take with your
Android device will be
instantly shared with
everybody invited
to the Event.
So that means, even if you
couldn't make the Event,
you're able to see all the
activity and participate from
your phone or your desktop.
KAVI HARSHAWAT: And after the
Event is over, all the photos
are collected in
a single place.
And you can view the most
popular photos, the ones that
have been plus oned or commented
the most at the top
of the page as Event
Highlights.
Photos can also be organized by
photographers or the people
who are tagged in them, so you
can see all the photos from
the people you want
to see them from.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And when
is this going to
be available then?
TINA CHEN: So on desktop
is rolling out today.
So you should see it soon.
If you go and install
the new Android app
for phone and tablet.
You should just get
that right away.
And it'll be available
in the iOS app store
pretty soon, too.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: This
is really cool.
Thank you so much.
TINA CHEN: Thank you.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Thanks,
Tina and Kavi.
We appreciate it.
TINA CHEN: You guys enjoy it.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And thank you,
Timothy-- yes, we will--
for being our tour guide here
in the Google+ Sandbox.
We've learned a lot.
We've seen a lot
of cool stuff.
And of course, we hope people
stay engaged with all this
discussion.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah,
we really do.
You know, the conversation
doesn't have to stop here.
Please check out our online
documentation.
You can find out more about
everything that we've talked
about today.
That's
developers.google.com/plus.
Join us in the discussion
forum.
And join us on Google+
as well.
DANIEL SIEBERG: I've got to get
my hands on one of those,
by the way.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah, me too.
All right, thanks, Daniel.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Thanks
so much, Timothy.
All right.
And stay tuned for
more on I/O Live.